is there something that you specifically
disagree with that ruslan talks about i
know he hasn't written a a book at least
i don't believe not yet which by the way
you have me inspired so
that was my
only my only beef was i i really wanted
to have this conversation with you
actually even before this is just like
i'm like i'm like at least go in knowing
what it is that i'm talking about
because what i think happens is like
guys get into
um like the influencer sphere and you
you're also an example of this too sorry
to say but like when guys like your your
show was primarily about money until you
met me it's all i ruined your life right
so like technically
technically i had already done
five relationship shows then you showed
up and i was like oh there's an actually
a [ __ ] handbook for this everybody
wants everybody wants a piece of them
atmosphere right now jedediah wants a
piece of the man everybody wants
something of it and it's easy pickings
for a lot of people who are sort of of
this moralist bent right now because
they hear uh kevin samuels talk about
things and they they lose their minds
when kevin samuels passed away it was
nothing but but hate from women
nothing but hate from women i mean i
mean to the point where they were saying
this is a gift from god that he died on
he not a mother's day right and so i'm
i'm watching this i'm going damn that is
a lot of victory are you are you
basically saying that well
it's sort of amazing
that it's it's opportunity to create
views topic du jour is what it is okay
and not just him i'd like like a lot of
people but i asked you specifically your
problem my problem is this is like
speaking from a position of ignorance
okay like it's and i've i brought this
this up with jedidiah as well like jedi
will say like oh yeah i watched like two
thirty second clips of fresh and fit and
i and i don't know much about them she
prefaces the whole thing about that but
let me tell you everything about them
and i'm right well why should we listen
to you if you're already prefacing this
would you like the church speaking with
your position
these are two questions here would you
consider jedi ignorant on that she is
very much ignorant on the right a lot of
people are but they want to jump in
because it it triggers this kind of
moralistic uh belief set where it's like
well that's not what i believe and let
me start talking about okay rather than
being making that's i'm thank you for
reading my books because that was the
first thing i said said at least read
your the book so you know where i'm
coming from before we have this
discussion i'm glad you did thank you
very much so hey is there a question no
well
my point is it's not me so much it's not
even so much he's done a lot of content
on this you've done stuff with our
friend huffy's you've done multiple like
yeah let me i don't think you're
ignorant to yourself let me back into it
because i think that's a that's a fair
point and i and it sound if she watched
two videos and started making a bunch of
anti-red pill content i would agree with
you you don't know what you're talking
about i don't know that's uh again if
that's a separate issue right we're
talking about pick and pull they're like
i agree with this and i don't agree with
you so therefore it's good so here's
what happened i i listen to my audience
i'm i don't know if you're engaged in
your comments i listen to my audience i
i go into the dms and so whatever people
are asking me and what do you think
about this then i'll check it out and i
won't just watch
instagram clips i don't even watch short
form contents i go watch long-form
content try to understand so what
happened was people reached out to me
said what do you think about kevin
samuels kevin samuels kevin simmons
that's where it started that's where it
started how long ago uh well when did
you watch
uh last may ish somewhere yeah last week
he passed away he passed away this past
may i was reacting to his stuff a year
before that like last summer just from a
timeline horizon you've been
researching or looking into the watching
community for a little over a year
and you've been doing this for i've been
well i've been in the masters for 20
years 20 years
and so and so what happened was when i
started hearing some of this stuff it
took me back to middle school i grew up
in san diego in the 90s
you know got arrested at age 11 and i
was around a bunch of guys what we were
into was these books was these books
called uh by iceberg slim
called pimp and it was a lot of the same
type of language and a lot of the same
thinking coming from iceberg slim that
influenced a lot of my close friends to
go on to be pimps and they started
pimping and they started making a lot of
money doing that and buying houses and
that kind of stuff and then a lot of
these guys ended up getting arrested and
going to jail for a long time but the
ideologies were very similar and this
and and i was like man this is so weird
that i'm seeing some of this stuff to
the point where i was you know i'm i'm
in middle school it's 97 98 around these
guys and then this followed people into
the early 2000s when people were i don't
know if you remember this snoop dogg
bishop magic wand they're dressing up as
pimps and of course if you ever saw the
movie old school like bring a green hat
bro
and iceberg slims
fictional literature or or maybe it
wasn't autobiography i don't know
exactly what it was influenced a lot of
my buddies to take on this mentality and
i saw overlap there now some people
would say iceberg slim pimp is
red pill i don't know if it is okay so
when i see kevin samuels i'm like man
there's some good stuff here he said
some interesting stuff i think they're
holding women accountable interesting
the way he talked about okay
what bugged me was that he kept
professing to be a leader of singles
ministries in churches and then would
turn around and say hi value men should
cheat that is what pissed me off because
now you're positioning yourself as a
christian authority and you're saying
that just because you make a certain
amount of money you're entitled to do
something not they do cheat that's what
i'm guessing that's kind of what your
position would be this is what happens
people make money exercise no he started
prescribing things and i don't know if
he was trying to be polarizing whatever
and so that is why i started commenting
and immediately after i started
commenting to those reactions because i
said well these are the logical
conclusions of this the nick cannons the
bill gates
right you you're going to lose money
this is the logical conclusion of high
value men should cheat as a high value
man in terms of what my net worth is and
what i'm this is this is stupid this is
asinine to me and then i connected with
hafiz 10 videos in and that's when he
kind of gave me some of the framework of
what what this is again he calls it an
ideology you call it a proxiology i know
that that kind of triggers you um that
that is how i came to i didn't come into
this because i just needed to react to
stuff my recommendations because people
asked me and i said oh there's some
overlap with this whole in the same way
andrew tate is saying he's an orthodox
christian i'm like okay this is
interesting people are what do you think
might have to entertain you know uh
faith that's why i'm reacting to it
right because i don't need the clicks i
can get views other ways if i wanted to
get views i'd just dunk on mega church
pastors all day that would go crazy for
my channel right i mean you know it is
right and so i that that's not the point
so that's how i got into it and then
yeah i saw your video and i said well
let me let me check out this guy rolo
research some of your stuff and here we
are yeah two two books later so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]